foreign
landscape of business strategic planners
stand as The Architects of success
wielding the blueprints that guide
organizations towards their goals as
companies strive to position themselves
advantageously amidst fear competition
and rapid changes the role of a
strategic planner becomes pivotal are
you ready to step into this Dynamic
realm and demonstrate your powers
Welcome to our comprehensive exploration
of strategic planner interview questions
and answers by simply Don a journey
where we dwell into the art of foresight
meticulous planning and decision making
fantasy whether you're an aspiring
strategic Mastermind or a seasoned
strategist aiming to refine your skills
join us as we dissect the inquiries that
unravel your strategic Acumen and
provide you with the key to unlocking a
world of possibilities that said if
these are the type of videos you'd like
to watch then hit that subscribe button
and the bell to get notified and if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn Sports
graduate program and business analysis
from Perth University in collaboration
with Amazon Google and Microsoft should
be your right choice for more details
use the link in the description box
below also if you're already a business
analyst and want to upgrade your skills
to become a successful data scientist
with proper training and certification
from the experts and repeated
universities then Caltech data science
bootcamp should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below so without further
Ado let's get started the first question
on the list is what are the key
differences between strategic planning
and business planning the answer for
this question is strategic planning is a
process of developing a long-term vision
for an organization and creating a plan
to achieve that Vision business planning
is the process of developing more
detailed plan for how the organization
will achieve its strategic goals now
moving further we have the second
question what are the three main
components of a strategic plan the
answer for this question is the three
main components of a strategic plan are
vision mission and strategy Vision a
clear statement of what the organization
wants to achieve in the long term
Mission a statement of the
organization's purpose and what it does
lastly strategy a set of goals and
objectives that the organization will
use to achieve its Vision now the third
question what are the five steps in the
strategic planning process the answer is
the five steps in the strategic planning
process are gathering information
analyzing information and developing the
plan implementing the plan and lastly
evaluating the plan gathering
information this involves collecting
data about the organization's internal
and external environment analyzing
information this involves interpreting
the data that has been collected
developing the plan this involves
creating a plan that outlines the
organized version Mission and strategy
implementing the plan this involves
putting the plan into action evaluating
the plan this involves monitoring the
plan's progress and making necessary
adjustments now the fourth question what
are some of the challenges of strategic
planning the answer for this question is
some of the challenges of strategic
planning include lack of resources
changing environment resistance to the
change lack of resources organizations
may not have the resources they need to
implement their strategic plans changing
environment the external environment is
constantly changing which can make it
difficult to develop a strategic plan
that is still relevant in the future
resistance to change employees May
resist change which can make it
difficult to implement strategic plan
now the fifth question what are some of
the benefits of strategic planning the
answer for this question is some of the
benefits of strategic planning include
increase based Focus strategic planning
helps organizations to focus on their
important goals improve the decision
making strategic planning provides a
framework for organizations for making
decisions that are aligned with the
organization's overall goals increased
efficiency strategic planning can help
organizations to become more efficient
by identifying and eliminating waste
improved performance strategic planning
can help organizations to improve their
performance by setting clear goals and
objectives now the sixth question
what are some of the trends that are
likely to impact strategic planning in
the future the answer to this question
is some of the trends that are likely to
impact strategic planning in the future
include globalization technology and
sustainability globalization the
increasing interconnectedness of the
world economy is likely to require
organizations to develop more globalized
strategic plans technology the rapid
pace of Technology change is likely to
require organizations to be constantly
innovating in order to stay ahead of the
competition sustainability the growing
awareness of environmental and social
issues is likely to require
organizations to develop a sustainable
strategic plans now moving into the
seventh question what are some of the
skills that are essential for a
strategic business planner the answer to
this question is some of the skills that
are essential for a strategic business
planner include the analytical skills
problem solving skills communication
skills and Leadership skills and
analytical skills strategic business
planners need to be able to gather
analyze and interpret data in order to
make informed decisions problem solving
skills strategic business planners need
to be able to identify and solve
problems in order to achieve the
organization's goals communication
skills strategic business planners need
to be able to communicate effectively
with a variety of stakeholders in order
to build consensus and support for the
organization's strategic plan leadership
skills strategic business planners need
to be able to lead and motivate others
in order to implement the organization's
strategic plan now 8th question what are
some of the challenges that you have
faced in your previous role as a
strategic business planner now this type
of question is something realistic that
you might have to work on so you have to
draft a detailed list of challenges and
benefits are any of the achievements you
have faced in your previous organization
and shoot the answer in a right way so
you can expect as this is a great
question to show the interviewer that
you are aware of the challenges of
strategic planning and that you have
skills and experience to overcome them
right so if you have a detailed plan and
detailed answer to this question this is
the impact what you are going to put on
your interviewer proceeding further we
have the eighth question tell me about
your experience in strategic planning
again this is also something real-time
question which happens to describe about
your experience and strategic planning
in your interview this is a great way
for the interviewer to get a sense of
your skills and experience in strategy
planning before be sure to highlight
your most relevant experiences and
explain how you have used strategic
planning to achieve results now the 10th
question
what are your strengths as a strategic
planner now this is again one more
important questions that you will be
facing in an interview so here your
interviewer is trying to know what
exactly are your strengths and
weaknesses while you're performing a
strategic plan so this question is an
opportunity for you to highlight your
skills and abilities as a strategic plan
be sure to focus on your strengths that
are relevant to the role you are
interviewing for now so far we have
finished up the top 10 interview
questions and answers based on strategy
planning profile but before we move
further let's hear from our Learners
about their personal experience and
their success story after getting
graduated from the business analytics
first graduate program offered by simply
learn in collaboration with IBM from
Purdue University
hi I'm Cortana rujak I live in Raleigh
North Carolina and working as a business
analyst at levator
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics I simply learned with Purdue
University my experience with simple
learning was great the live classes were
my favorite because they were very
interactive and I could connect with
instructors many small gaps and short
Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
it doesn't matter how challenging the
path may be keep upscaling and one day
you will achieve successful feeling
inspired already consider checking the
business analysis postgraduate program
offered by simply learn from Purdue
University in collaboration with IBM for
more details use the link in the
description box below now the 11th
question
what are your weaknesses as a strategy
planner so the answer is again realistic
no one is perfect and the interviewer
knows this this question is an
opportunity for you to be honest about
your weaknesses but also to explain how
you are working to improve them now the
12th question how do you stay up to date
on the latest trends and strategic
planning the answer for this question is
strategic planning is an ever-evolving
field so it's important to stay up to
date on the latest trends be sure to
mention the ways in which you stay
informed such as reading industry
Publications attending conferences and
taking online classes now 13th question
can you give me an example of a time
when you use data to make a strategic
decision again one more real-time
interview question so here you need to
demonstrate your skills and your ability
of making a strategic decision based on
data so you can make use of your
previous experiences here this question
is a great way to generate straight your
ability to use data to make informed
decisions be sure to choose an example
that is relevant to the role you are
interviewing for and the highlights of
your skills in data analysis and
interpretation moving further we have
the 14 question how do you measure the
success of your strategic plans the
answer for this question is it's
important to be able to measure the
success of your strategic plans in order
to track progress and make necessary
adjustments be sure to mention the
specific metrics you used to measure
success and how you use this data to
improve your plans now the 15th question
how do you build consensus among
stakeholders the answer for this
question is strategic planning often
requires input from a variety of
stakeholders be sure to mention the
specific strategies you use to build
consensus such as active listening
compromise and other clear
Communications now the 16th question how
do you manage risk in your own strategic
planning the answer is no strategic plan
is without risk be sure to mention the
specific strategies you use to manage
your risk such as scenario planning
contingency plans and is communication
techniques now proceeding further we
have the 17th question what is your
experience with using data analytics and
strategic planning the answer is you
have to build second so the genetic
answer you can give to your interviewer
is I have extensive experience using
data analytics and strategic plan in my
previous role I used data analytics to
identify Trends develop forecasts and
make informed decisions about the
organization's strategic Direction I am
proficient in using a variety of data
analytic tools and techniques and I am
confident in my ability to use data to
drive strategic plans now 18th question
how do you measure the success of a
strategic plan the answer is I measure
the success of a strategic plan by
tracking the organization's progress
against its goals and objectives I also
use surveys interviews and other
qualitative methods to gather feedback
from stakeholders about the plan's
Effectiveness I am confident that my
approach to measuring strategic plan
success is comprehensive and accurate
now going ahead we have another
realistic question which is about how do
you manage risk and strategic planning
the answer can be generic I manage risk
and strategic planning by identifying
and accessing potential risks developing
contingency plans and implementing risk
mitigation strategies I am also
proficient in using scenario planning to
anticipate and prepare for future
challenges I am confident that my
approach to managing risk and strategic
planning is proactive and effective with
that we have reached the last question
in this list don't worry we have two
more questions which are a little
different from the any questions so
before that let's finish the answer for
the 20th question the answer for this
question is I believe that strategic
planning is more important than ever in
a fast-paced ever-changing environment
in order to succeed in today's economy
organizations need to be able to adapt
quickly to change and stay ahead of the
competition strategic planning provides
a framework for making informal
decisions about the organization's
future in a rapidly changing environment
now with this let's proceed further and
look into some futuristic or realistic
questions that your organization or your
interviewer is about to ask you so they
might be asking you about the future
plans or future Transit strategic
planning or do you have any questions
that type of question which might be
different from the routine interview so
one of those questions is what are your
thoughts on future of strategic plan
this is a great new entity on it allows
you to share your thoughts on the future
of strategic planning and how do you see
your role evolving in this particular
field now next question on this
particular type is
do you have any questions for me the
answer is this is your chance to ask any
questions you have about the room or the
company be sure to ask thoughtful
questions that demonstrate your interest
in this position now with this we have
reached to the end of this session on
strategic planner into the questions and
answers should you need any assistance
PPT or other resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section Below on our team of
experts we'll be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching stay tuned for more
from Simply gone
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here